head over to
losingmymind.com to check out our latest
song genocide support our work now onto
the show
if you look at men their grip strength
is going down women's grip strength is
going up Men's testosterone is going
down their sperm levels are going down
reproduction rates are going down family
units are going down there's a lot of
different things that we could attribute
it's so delicious but I think I could
read that's no stop it don't you mind
though how dare you I will so much I
will drop dead because of Code Red I
will you probably will it will be the
thing that kills me I will guess I will
be so fat I don't know if those rumors
are just urban legends or whatever but I
want to get back to this question here
is what is responsible for it and and
how do we fix this overall problem how
do you see the how do you quantify the
problem how do you fix it so um
capitalism um wants maximum freedom
because maximum Freedom means maximum
profits uh and that works on both the
supply and and
um but it works at every point in the
chain right so the more workers you have
the better the more people who can work
the better because the more diverse the
workforce is the less likely they are to
unionize which is why big business is in
favor of diversity because it makes
their work for easier to abuse and and
to manage that's the reason big business
likes diversity because if you have a
Workforce made up of people who can
barely speak each other's languages they
are never going to get together well let
me add to that too when the rules are so
uh atomized you can get someone in
trouble for anything anybody who is
acting out of line you can say oh well
you're violating this provision this I
believe is a manifestation of a
frustrated maternal Instinct
um from women who should have had
children and didn't uh and it's become a
sort of um uh it's become this kind of
out of control turbocharged policing of
others this attempt to impose uh order
on uh um on the world
um and and you know I I lay the blame
for this the feet of men who um you know
it's it's the job of a husband to
establish the parameters within which
his family will operate these are the
things that I will accept and these are
the things that I will not accept and
and he counts on his partner to to
express those wishes in her daily
decisions and how she raises the
children
well men haven't been doing that for a
really long time
and the result has been Anarchy
and not just like not just chaos but
like true epistemological Anarchy
they're they're like multiple fact
universes in America now there are
people who believe completely different
pictures of what they think are as
objective reality right because instead
of politics being
um a a you know the art of the possible
grounded in reason now we have
um competing narratives and these
narratives are are completely factually
divorced from one another and in most
cases from from reality themselves as
well this is the result of um this is a
feminization of discourse uh because we
become untethered from Mr Banks's reason
and discipline which always falls on the
man to uh to to hold online and instead
we begin to indulge in um I mean to put
it in grammatical terms right uh women
live in the subjunctive they live in the
world of the possible right uh and they
the the the economy of value for women
is completely different than it is for
men
no man really understands until he has
explained to him why women like
expensive handbags so why do you want
this thing that costs five thousand
dollars it's not worth five thousand
everybody knows it's not and what he
doesn't understand is that the price
point is part of the future a feature
set for a woman because when she
exhibits this handbag to others she's um
signaling that she has snagged a high
status husband that she's secure that
she's safe and that she's part of um uh
an ongoing and secure Dynasty that will
outlive her and that she has acquired a
secure and enviable position in the pack
in the social packing order and that
social packing order you know is a
preoccupation of you know the the parish
uh you know
um scolds of popular Legend uh
men don't understand that um
buying the big diamond that makes no
sense because uh the the association
with diamonds and Eternity and lovers
and eventually ad industry right like
yeah it was a scam it's it's a it's a
complete confection but it's meaningful
now and it matters now
um because it's an expression of
something that
women want to see in their husbands is
um that they will do anything the grand
gestures the romantic gestures even
where it imperils their own um uh
pleasure well-being to demonstrate
publicly demonstrate their love for this
woman right and then they want to build
a home with a man who they don't
necessarily always agree with but they
always admire and respect and they they
the deal is I'll do what you say even
when I don't agree with you because I
respect and admire and trust you enough
to let you set the parameters for you
know for the for the the household yeah
when men fail in their duties to set
those parameters women expand endlessly
with no limits and we see that in in in
in in HR departments I mean the reason
that people like me can't get Podcast
deals is that the ad sales department is
entirely feminine uh it's it's 100 women
um and so so the vice president will be
like I love you I just can't get these
women to sell you to advertisers because
they're going to come up with a bunch of
reasons why you're whatever
um the the economy of value is so
completely different and and you know
when people stray into areas that are
not the proper domain and that could be
a husband interfering in some thing that
happens domestically
um or it could be a woman in in a
conventionally male sphere
it's a trap it's an illusion it seems
that first like Freedom emancipation but
actually it is enslavement yeah just to
really I agreed on a lot but I disagreed
on one thing I don't think it's it's
related to Anarchy I think it's related
to centralization especially when it
comes to things like the ESG score that
has been pushing a lot of these social
norms on to people I I think you know
the industrialists the governments
especially with the policies they put
forward the initiatives that they put
forward and what they do and what they
incentivize truly has been leading to a
society that is creating more slaves and
the state having more power there's a
centralizing tendency in uh matriarchies
because they're trying to recreate the
patriarchy that's let them down they're
trying to recreate the um the the the
patriarchy that that failed them by by
disappearing right so they're trying to
recreate it except they don't know how
because they don't have the tools right
just like you know this the reason Satan
Rebels and because you know becomes
Lucifer is that he is driven mad by by
jealousy because
God gives women a gift that Angels don't
have
and it's the gift of co-procreation with
God right when you within the holy
sacrament of marriage are blessed with a
child you don't just create a child with
your husband but you are co-creating
with God because while you produce the
biological matter God imbused that child
with an immortal Soul so in in that
Sacrament your husband and wife are
engaging in the Act of Creation
alongside
their Almighty father
it's like
look you know we talk about forever but
but
the Angels didn't get that
um and and driven mad by jealousy and
and rage at um what he saw as the sort
of preferred younger sibling um this is
the basis for for the Rebellion right
um that should that should frame our
understanding when we talk about this
it's not that we think that women are
stupid or incompetent clearly they can
manage perfectly well in these spheres
whether the effect is good or not you
know is is another matter but clearly
they can they can handle it
um
but it's allowing uh encouraging them or
enticing them to do so as big business
does because it's good for the bottom
line
is only possible when you set to one
side
the reality of the the magic and
responsibility an Incredible Gift that
women have that we don't I thought that
was really uh I guess inspiring what you
said about
Society kind of becoming overly mothered
because women aren't having enough
children and so they're turning that
motherly Instinct outward it's got to go
somewhere they're built for it they're
built for it and and if they choose if
they if they are lied to and choose
their career over um having babies
it has to come out somewhere so what do
they do they end up in HR where they get
to make rules just like they would if
they were a mom this is funny we uh we
talked about this because there was a
story we read and I mentioned that there
are some women not all not most but
there are some women we see posting on
things like Tinder that they wish they
just were able to have families and
didn't have to have careers and The
Young Turks took that and turned it into
Tim Poole thinks all women or some like
Temple's ridiculous argument about women
it's it's it's it's fascinating that you
can't even acknowledge that some women
feel that way there's a there's a
there's a counter-intuitive
um but inescapably true uh fact which is
that the Freer women have gotten the
more miserable they have uh become well
how about uh just one quick point in
Sweden where women have more equal
access the gender differences are
actually more pronounced yeah
um because people are so desperate for
them uh
you can you can neatly uh trace the
history of women's emancipation
um and it tacks directly on to
um how women report their own increasing
misery and also the antidepressants use
and also big Pharma tablets ssris
which have gone up with that
unsatisfaction one in ten Americans on
um on on antidepressants uh half of all
Democrat women so they've been to the
doctor for mental health problems
um you know that's that's that's not
normal and it doesn't happen elsewhere
in the world it doesn't happen in other
places yeah we medicate their misery and
and yes and this is well we we the
pharmaceutical model of mental health uh
is only capable of treating symptoms uh
it can't fix what's wrong with you
because it doesn't account for existence
of a soul at all it treats the body as a
purely uh mechanical
um uh uh machine as a machine and if
only we could find out which bit needs
more oil or which bid is a it needs
replacing we can fix your depression
well that's not the nature of depression
uh that's not the nature of of most
mental illnesses
um we just recently discovered finally
that the um psychiatric industry
admitted that there is no basis for the
um for the
accepted wisdom that depression is a
chemical imbalance they can't find it
they can't prove it so it might be that
depression is a product um maybe of of
guilt about uh about Sin that has not
been
um uh you know that no Absolution has
been sought for of terrible things about
all kinds of possibilities let me open
up but but the the current system is is
is totally incapable of of healing it's
only capable of um dealing with the
symptoms placating in a way that
produces new and worse problems like
addictions yeah I mean the the the the
the the the range of
um temptations that are uh available so
we don't understand addiction very well
because we don't understand the brain
very well but the one thing we do know
is the uh the the main difference
between people who relapse and people
who don't is is it available is it right
there right so people who stay away from
um you know from the junkie uh uh
Hangouts all the rest of it it's not in
front of them so they're less likely to
relapse uh if the that's the the one
thing we do know about it right
we are force-fed I mean this country's
Force feeds people with
a bewildering array of uh potential
addictions whether it's to compound
interest or um uh um
competitive uh sort of consumer purchase
TVs cars I mean none of you own your
cars none of you own your car I've never
bought a car in any way other than
outright and in cash
um and in this country people burn money
uh jumping from car to car like saying
goodbye to 20 grand each time and making
endless repayments that will never be
fully paid down I mean your whole life
is enslaved to interest to to people who
don't do anything for for
um for the money they make which is
usury which is a sin
um you know people who are entirely
parasitic I mean the basis of um the
basis of value in the economy is human
labor right uh it's people doing stuff
um these industries that are uh designed
to profit uh without effort there's a
reason that the church you know uh
regards this as Sinister and sinful
because it is
um and and
the the the the manner in which we are
presented I mean you know I think that
mostly what people said about video
games in the 80s and 90s was stupid and
what people say about Marilyn Manson was
like pretty stupid
um but the religious right was was
pretty bang on about everything else now
however when you consider as part of the
overall kind of junk food
drink prescription drugs I mean
I can't it's it's a wonder that I mean I
think every every American basically has
two of the of the ten categories but but
wrestling you know it's not normal it's
not normal yeah this is this is an
abusive relationship
um and and I so I'll be quick I'm sorry
I'm sorry um the the in in just the same
way that many of these cultural problems
have come from women's suffrage
um the failure of the institutions to
protect people is a result of American
independence because
when you throw away
the monarch
you don't really just get rid of him you
make space for something else to move in
uh and you might not have control over
that so America is now in a position
where they are ruled more brutally and
more savagely and more abusively than
any Monarch in living memory anywhere in
the world but they don't know the names
of the people who are doing it to them
it's central banks and they deserve
that's for sure certainly there are
certainly they're a part of it but what
instead you have is the empty Pomp and
Circumstance of the Fourth of July this
Rippling flag
um why do you love the flag so much
because there's room to hide behind it
and the people who are really running
the show whose names none of us will
ever learn
um are are what moved in
um instead of okay instead of having
okay and and you know people will differ
on this very violently I appreciate that
I'm probably taking minority view on
this but
um when we when we think about how the
Earthly order should reflect the
Heavenly order
um that that's the that's the the sort
of basis legitimacy of the papacy and
the monarchy right
um the way that societies are are
ordered
um reflects the Heavenly order and and
conforms to Nature and the way that and
our nature the way that we would design
the way the way that we work
um and those are the best and happiest
systems to live under they work the best
I the the
removal of the Monarch from the top and
then these kind of weird self-sabotaging
things like we're just gonna
we're just gonna trust that everybody's
gonna be Christian so we'll Outsource
morality to Christianity and we'll give
people these extraordinary freedoms that
don't exist anywhere else
um that wreck Society unless the whole
population is christian right you cannot
give people the first and second
amendment unless they're Christian you
just can't because only with that kind
of um uh incredible reverence for this
actually of Life can you trust people
with weapons of war
um and only with the responsibility that
comes with knowing that you have to go
to confession for lying can you be
trusted with uh freedom to say anything
about consequence I agree with the with
your statement on second I think that
the founding father's perspective on
society dictated their view of why
everyone should be armed they trusted
each other they they all thought each
other had some uh fear of doing wrong I
just don't think they anticipated that
the society would become Godless uh I
think you know we're talking about 1700s
right uh I mean you're you're living in
the
um you're living in the wake of the King
James Bible which changes everything
because it's
uh it's you know people people sometimes
try to like demean it by saying it's a
you know the greatest work of literature
in history which is you know true but
stop
um the way that the America's founding
documents are phrased and the way that
the founders spoke is
um heavily heavily influenced to the
point of dictated by the language and
the style of the king of the King James
Bible which came out in the early 1600s
right so when this this country is
founded in the wake of this
extraordinary
um moment unique in the history of ideas
where one book like changes everything
and and sort of uh uh defines everything
that follows it
I don't know did they ever imagine I
mean when they when they enshrined
freedom of religion they were thinking
about just like making sure that
Protestant denominations weren't at each
other's throats they weren't intending
for uh ilhan Omar to come in and say
some people did something and for her to
be uh uh sitting in Congress
um allegedly from a family involved in
very ugly things in her home country of
Somalia um uh she couldn't possibly have
sought election in this country for uh
virtuous reasons I can't imagine what
they would have been
um this is not what was intended and
that's you know this ugly phrase
Christian nationalism um that uh people
are are so afraid of what it really is
is um my view is uh is is a restitution
of the original vision for America but
with a few more safeguards in place
um so it's it's a it's a acknowledgment
that this country doesn't work without
Christianity uh it falls to pieces and
it is falling to pieces um thanks to
godlessness why because those
understandings of the proper places and
roles and functions of things aren't in
the law anywhere the existing common law
and in Tradition and in custom in Europe
but this break this rupture that happens
with this Edition and the and and
getting rid of the king resets the clock
in America and there's none of those
things to draw and just trusting that
people are going to stay Christian and
therefore be nice to each other was
stupid
I one thing I I don't necessarily agree
with is that or what there's a statement
you know we're made in the image of God
the universe is like we're like fractals
of reality so like there's one God hence
one Monarch and that is that now any
Christians who talk about fractals of
reality oh it's just scientific you know
observations you do a lot of LSD not a
lot but I have a little bit yeah keep
your dosages low enough to stay sane my
friends my a very dear friend of mine
who's a very gifted photographer does um
a little micro doses of LSD and he has a
similar similar phrasing to you oh cool
um well what I'm thinking is see that
you see everybody thinks that they have
this um extraordinary unique experience
that turns them into a genius but they
all sound exactly the same I'm just
kidding I'm sorry uh Carol oh so there's
one God that I I agree that there is in
in one sense one overarching magnetic
field or whatever the hell God is but
then there's also within that it can be
broken down to do infinite Gods all
infinite Fields creating one Mega field
so in that sense we could have one king
or we could have a decentralized system
of many many local leaders I think
you've broken your brain well it's two
ways of looking at this one this sounds
like astrology for men
um you what LSD does in creating those
new Connections in the brain which
produce the um you know moments of
inspiration is uh it disorders the uh uh
established Pathways and while it's
thrilling and exciting and can make
people sound very interesting uh it also
gets in the way of um
critical thinking because your
e there's there's a sort of um people
have done a lot of LSD they have this
infatuation with this way they see the
world now they think they've got this uh
um Insight that nobody else has uh into
the nature of reality when actually
um they're just confused by a bunch of
things being stuck together have you
done LSD uh no mercifully not you should
do it before you talk about it I uh I
don't need to kill someone to know
murder's wrong no um there are things
there are things that I'm happy to trust
that I shouldn't try and and you know
that that's um that's another another
that's another thing about women's
suffrage is um it's a kind of violation
of the Innocence of women that Menace
are attracted to I mean the the soil
that nourishes that protective instinct
is the is there Purity and innocence of
young women who are unsullied by the
ugliness of the world you know
um and and uh men can go out and be uh
Reckless and wreck their brains and and
uh and uh you know make make terrible
mistakes and all the rest of it but but
when when you inject women into a sphere
that um that they're not created to
flourish in
um it does something
uh inexcusable to them it is an
imposition on them that I think that we
owe them an enormous apology for for uh
for for and um uh and we should try to
set it right yeah what you said earlier
I found very interesting but I I would
even in some instances go even further
because you talked about godlessness I
would say there's even elements of just
pure Satanism in our society in our
establishment especially when you look
at people like Jeffrey Epstein when you
look at all the celebrities when you
look at the all the occult stuff the
rappers are doing it uh doing um uh
Satanic rituals yeah yeah there's like
sacrifices Lady Gaga leaves a bathtub of
blood in her hotel room but that's a
whole other topic before even getting
there but but also I I want to talk
about I want to talk about what you said
about institutions because you said
institutions aren't protecting people I
would even go as far as to say that the
institutions are attacking people
especially when it comes to the way of
life especially what they incentivize
and I think it's the institutions that
are a problem so so how do we go back to
that we've given ourselves AIDS so the
white blood cells that should protect us
are attacking us instead exactly so so
how do we fix this problem because it
seems like a lot of the the solutions
you have is okay let's let's support
Trump let's let's support these strong
institutions these institutions are
corrupted how do we fix these
institutions how do we make them work
for us again America is doomed without a
reversal of the Sedition that sealed its
fate
um which is
American independence
um I'm afraid I'm afraid to say it's all
encoded it sounds like something a
British person would say yes it does
um but there's a reason but there's a
reason I'm here and not there it's
because I like it here better
um and I want America to succeed into
and to win and it would have done so
better as um as a
member of the Commonwealth in good
standing uh it might not have had some
of the uh
remarkable Financial successes uh such
as they are
um you know but but
I can't really imagine in 500 years
people are going to be uh discussing the
Real Housewives of Atlanta
um I don't know that the lasting Legacy
of America is going to be particularly
um valuable compared to other Empires
that have been as Grand as rich and um
as uh as long lasting
um somebody wrote an essay I forget now
because I'm old but um uh as one of your
viewers will know I'm sure about
um uh polarity and the fact that for a
long time America we lived in a unipolar
world right where America was kind of
the tentpole
um I think the effect of that has been
unquestionably damn uh damaging and
destructive
um and it might not be such a bad thing
for us to return to a multi-polar
um world with with multiple uh perhaps
competing superpowers
um where there are other visions of of
what a good life looks like I mean Putin
is obviously uh personally uh deeply
unpleasant and maybe maybe even
hideously evil person depending on how
much you believe of what he's supposed
to have done but there's something very
exciting about the way he talks about
cultural issues
um and and it's wounding when he is
Savage about the failures of the West
because he's right about so much of it
and it's easy to do from there and you
know there's all kinds of Horrors and in
uh in in Russia when you can't even get
your mail delivered without bribing the
mailman I mean it's like practically
that bad I mean Russia is not really a
functioning Society without uh you know
it's like it's like Greece really I mean
anything done at all you need a lot of
cash
um it's it's you know it's all kinds of
problems but but
the the I think I think something that
Russia has preserved that the West
hasn't is
um the the high standard of
public discourse the tone of which is
like typically set by the Prime Minister
the president demonic
um when When Vladimir Putin speaks to
the Russian people he does so in Grand
historical terms that nobody in the west
has done for 50 years or more
when you compare it to the the
witless prattle of of most American
presidents in that time the
um pathetic uh uh pandering of most
European leaders
we have become
captives of this feminized discourse
that treats everybody what why what is
the reason for the nanny and culture
this this uh um intrusive invasive and
destructive uh uh thing it's
feminization of culture that seeks to
seeks to control what everybody says and
everybody doesn't want to say um that's
that's that's you know the primary
problem in America is not race it's
between the Sexes because the Sexes uh
have uh completely failed to fulfill
their
um uh their promise and their
obligations uh men and women now alike
admittedly probably original sin being
men the men's you know a failure of Duty
but men and women are now completely
failing to to perform the rightful
functions and so in the world in a
globalized information economy where
words are powerful
um well that's the arena of women you
know words are a woman's weapon so women
uh wield this kind of like outsized
influence and ability in um social you
know on social media so these become
very very uh heavily policed very
feminine places really fast because is I
mean you know the way that men typically
settle things I can't talk about the
podcast it's a bit different um or at
least there's a kind of uh um bubbling
underlying ever-present threat of
something else when men are talking you
know um but women use language very
differently and that's what we see now
how everybody talks now I just I'm so
struck by
the way that you know Matthew Arnold
said that everybody no matter where they
come from the working class living in a
trailer they deserve to be exposed to
the very best that has been thought and
and written thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time